Будемо починати знайомитись Мене звуть
свят Бойко Я сьогодні буду з вами як
ведучий будемо спілкуватися будемо
говорити і будемо висловлювати свою
думку тому що ми маємо на це право я
дякую кожному з вас я дякую всім і
кожному за те що попри негоду за те що
попри холод попри сніг ми всі зібралися
тут туди представники з кожного регіону
України правда ж
Так Київ є
який Західна Україна
славетна північ
[оплески]
та південь України
наших східняки є є
центральна Україна
Крим
є Крим
Донецьк Луганськ є
наші тому що це ж Україна брати і сестри
Дякую кожному з вас за вашу активність
за вашу позицію за те що
ви маєте сміливість сьогодні і не тільки
сьогодні А повсякчас висловлювати свою
думку а вона є
неабияк важливою
друзі традиційно розпочнемо
наш захід
хто мені підкаже з чого
правильно зі спільного виконання
державного гімну України
[музика]
ще нам браття
українці
усміхнеться
доля
Згинуть наші
воріженьки як роса на сонці
Запануєм і ми браття у
своїй сторо
нці
Душу й тіло ми
положим за нашу свобо
і покажем що ми
браття козацького
[музика]
роду
[оплески]
душу й тіло ми
положим за нашу свобо
Ду і
покажем що ми браття козацького
[музика]
роду
Слава Україні
а нації
[оплески]
україна! Україна
Путін
Василя
саме народу глаголить істина
ти сестри Ми всі тут щоб сказати своє
рішуче ні
зелені диктатурі
наш пів-шостий вирішив що він може бути
таким як наш Північний сусід
треба треба мати сталеві яйця щоб бути
хоча б кимось
Ну на жаль він є ніким але думає і
вважає що він є великим і найвеличнішим
Та так воно не є і його планом ми будемо
ставити кінець ми будемо ставити крапку
тому що Останнє слово завжди за народом
І тільки так І зараз я хочу запросити до
слова людину яка про зелену диктатуру
про репресії знає нещоток а з власного
На жаль досвіду
нереально крута людина яка свого часу до
звільнення Маріуполя доклала чи не
найбільше зусиль легендарний генерал
Павловський
Доброго дня всім
ви знаєте Ми сьогодні тут зібрались
чергове щоб припинити те свавілля яке
триває сьогодні над патріотами України
яким вже потрібно бути недолугим або
якими повинно бути недолугими
правоохоронним органам щоби в 14-му році
15-16-19
сказати що верховний головнокомандувач є
зрадником України
Який отримав Україну Який підняв військо
який згуртував нашу націю і ми живемо
сьогодні в нашій вільній державі маємо
право на слово маємо право на честь
маємо право на виховання гідне виховання
своїх дітей але на жаль ми маємо право
на нормальне правосуддя
яке судить по амбіціям а не по закону не
по тим законам які виписані для нашого
народу не по тим законам які створені
для нашого суспільства
Я маю честь відстоювати сьогодні разом з
вами права на честь і гідність нашого
суспільства я дякую всім за ту підтримку
яку надав мені народу України і Я
впевнений що ми не дамо з ганьбити ім'я
нашого головнокомандувача і честь нашого
п'ятого президента Слава Україні
Україна
і То є правда Україна таки понад усе
понад усі матеріально цінності понад усі
скарби світу
Україна є понад усе зараз до слова
запрошую
політика експерта з багатьох
справді з багатьох питань надзвичайно
розумна людина
екс-депутат Верховної Ради
журналіст Сергій Висоцький
Дякую Дякую Слава Україні
Дякую що ви сьогодні тут з нами Дякую що
ви прийшли відстоювати демократію до
свободу захищати людину яка в
найтяжкіші часи захищала нас з вами
відбудовувала військо робила все для
того щоб путінські російська весна
обламалася і сьогодні його судять знаєте
я коли виступаю на різних програмах в
тому числі на своїй завжди кажу просту
річ ви можете бути будь за кого
політично ви можете голосувати за того
за кого хочете ви можете любити
Порошенка чи не любити Порошенка але ви
не можете казати ні і не спостерігати
того що зараз руйнується саме право
українців на вибір зараз руйнується сама
Свобода зараз руйнується та сама де
ситуація і та сама воля і та сама
гідність яку ми з вами виборювали в
14-му році і яка завжди відрізняла нас
від кого від путінського Росії зараз те
що будує Володимир Зеленський в нашій
країні переслідуваннями Петра Порошенка
в'ячеславами картами справами проти
опозиції це пародія така пародія 95-го
кварталу на путинську Росію а він сам
маленька пародія на Путіна знаєте коли
такі речі починаються в Україні ми
завжди спостерігаємо просту
закономірність закінчується демократія
закінчується Європа із політичними
переслідуваннями з тим щоби нищити
проукраїнського демократичного позицію
нас радо завжди зустрічає де в тайожном
Союзі я хочу сказати і хочу щоб ви мене
підтримували в Європі так та Южному
Союзу ні в Європі так
стаёжному Союзу ні в Європі так та
Южному Союзу ні
Сьогодні ми боремось за Петра Порошенка
але боремося за саму українську
демократію а щодо самого Петра
Олексійовича можуть тільки сказати одне
завдяки таким зусиллям Володимира
Олександровича Зеленського він полетів
перед Новим роком п'ятим Президентом
України а повернеться сьомом Президентом
України п'ятий сьомий п'ятий сьомий
п'ятий
сьомий тому тому сьогодні довгий день
прошу на розходитись прошу потім бути
під судом і захищаємо не просто Петра
Порошенка захищаємо саму Україну
демократію наш євроатлантичний вибір
Слава Україні Дякую
Слава Україні
Путін
будет
Путин
борамидали
Будемо продовжувати селя
Амінь
кілька технічних оголошень насамперед
якщо ви раптом побачите які скажімо
незрозумілі групи молодиків тому що наша
акція є абсолютно мирною і ми знаємо що
влада спробує дискредитувати її Якщо ви
побачите якісь підозрілі групи молодиків
серед вас є Брати по зброї товариство в
камуфляжній формі
вони можуть бути з бейжами охорона
немає вони з шевронами Брати по зброї на
руках є шеврони
інформацію про ці групи людей зразу
передаємо або братам по зброї або нашим
волонтерам від справи громад також
важливо якщо побачити
десь хтось комусь роздає умовно гроші
тому що така інформація була що можуть
бути такі підстави
також і цю інформацію передаємо
передаємо братам по зброї і активісти
нашим волонтерам від справи громад і по
можливості фіксуємо це на відео
друзі
у боротьбі з маленькими диктаторами не
до диктаторами власне теми які хочуть
стати такими дуже
помічним є тролінг веселий хороший
добрий тролінг І зараз я на цю нашу
імпровізовану сцену хочу запросити Ну
мабуть короля політичного тролінгу в
народі його називають гудок А за
паспортом і за
і за своєю посадою за становищем тої
голова політичної партії демократична
сокира Юрій гудименко
що Як настрій друзі
слабо а ну давайте ще раз як настрої
друзі
оце краще Запоріжжя тут є
Приїжджайте до Києва
Я радий всіх тут бачити сьогодні
сподіваюсь вас стільки ж енергії скільки
в мене
народ сьогодні важливий день Чому він
важливий тому що ми тут зібралися
сьогодні
відстояти наше Завтра ми зібралися тут
для того щоб нашої країни було майбутнє
і в цьому майбутньому були принципи
принципи - це таке слово яке забула одна
людинка що зараз сидить на банковій
трясеться
є таке слово принципи принципи говорять
на про те що Президент має займатися
своєю справою
верховний головнокомандувач має
обороняти Україну
президент має займатися дипломатією а не
саджати опозицію в тюрми ось навіщо ми
тут для того щоб Україна була країною
принципів і для того щоб у неї було
завтра я хочу щоб у неї було завтра я
хочу щоб у моїх дітей було завтра я хочу
щоб ми не збиралися тут По понеділках а
спокійно працювали на благо нашої країни
але зараз ми не можемо цього зробити
Ми не можемо тому що Зеленський і його
недолугі
сателіти дякую
зібралися І вирішили що вони Влада але
Влада дає народ а Народ зараз тут а не
Зеленський
Я хотів би тому що знаю що на банкові
зараз пильно стежать за виступами з цієї
сцени за тим що відбувається тут під
аеропортом Я хотів би разом з вами
сказати зелю геть землю геть гелю геть
землю геть землю геть землю геть гелю
гей
гей гей гей гей гей гей ге
[оплески]
й коли хтось спитає у вас
Що ви робили сьогодні що ви зробили
сьогодні корисного для вашої країни у
вас є відповідь і тільки у вас сьогодні
ви відстоювали для всіх нас наша завтра
дякую вам за це Слава Україні
разом сила
РЕ
[музика]
Тільки в єдності є наша сила я це говорю
завжди і повсякчас кожного дня кожного
моменту коли Власне цей момент настає
кожної нагоди Я говорю про те що в
єдності є наша з вами сила коли ми разом
Подивіться як говорив колись Віталій
Кличко один палець Він не є сильним але
коли ці п'ять пальців збираються в кулак
виходить власне потужна Ударна сила і
власне Кожен з нас є отим пальчиком і ми
разом Ми разом створюємо отой ударний
кулак який буде робити зміни власне
за нами товариство є майбутнє кожна наша
акція вона відзначається підтримкою
активної підтримкою нашого лідера нашої
політичної сили громадськими діячами
музикантами людьми від мистецтва Я не
кажу що музиканти - це люди не від
мистецтва тому що я сам є музикантом
наші акції - це завжди зібрання
усміхнених позитивних адекватних людей
які чудово розуміють чого вони хочуть і
зараз на цю сцену Я хочу запросити
надзвичайного музиканта художника
громадського діяча Юрій Журавель
[музика]
інер гурту аквинта
Здоровенькі були Наші дорогенькі
порохоботи порохосестри Так я Юрій
Журавель лідер рок-гурту От вінта
очільник творчої спільноти з най наших
художник і Люстратор і Люстратор
Справа в тому що я приїхав сьогодні з
міста Рівного і поки їхав в дорозі
познайомився з хлопцем Віктором він до
речі серед вас він серед вас але він
голосував за Зеленського знаєте чому І
от дорогою Він розказав чому чому він
тут Тому що спочатку він сказав було
весело дійсно по приколу потім
йому стало соромно А потім
гидко а потім страшно він страшно
розчарувався я не розчарувався тому що я
знав що так буде І я вкотре звертаюсь да
Володимира Зеленського Володя Візьміть з
голову починає працювати якщо ти вліз в
Це крісло
Ти занадто глибоко ввійшов
в цю роль
в чужому фільмі з чужими режисерами за
чужим сценарієм і я не знаю подивіться
що ви робите ви шиєте справу Петру
Порошенку про державну зраду
Легше Я не знаю і набагато
правдоподібніше і набагато веселіше мене
посадити за згвалтування всього
Рівненського зоопарку
[музика]
тому я не знаю дійсно візьми за голову а
просто зараз я хочу передати гарячий
ющій привіт від Рівненщини Волині і
Полісся Слава Україні
[оплески]
тут все добре на цій території
От бачите недопрацьовують наші спікери
тому що я за них путі
ля Амінь
Я би сказав трошки перефразовуючи
класика Юрія журавля Я би сказав Володя
візьмися за голову і йди займайся тим що
ти вмієш робити
народився піскограєм піскограєм буть Іди
грай на роялі іди весели публіку іди
весели народ на корпоративах чи в саунах
де ти там веселив його займайся тим що
ти вмієш робити Іди геть з
президентського крісла тому що загрався
насправді загрався брати і сестри до
мікрофона запрошую громадського діяча
публіциста
перекладача
письменника мого доброго товариша Дмитра
чекалкіна
[оплески]
Вітаю Вітаю вас друзі Дякую за
запрошення взяти участь сьогоднішній
акції ви знаєте Вчора був день пам'яті
героїв кіборгів героїв Донецького
аеропорту
Сьогодні ми воюємо на два фронти один
фронт лишається там під Донецьком а
другий фронт тут у Києві в іншому
аеропорту аеропорту Жуляни в аеропорту
Київ Ми не маємо права сьогодні лишити
Гетьмана без нашої підтримки ви знаєте я
свого часу відчував страшенний біль
через те що два з половиною роки тому
країна зробила таку величезну помилку в
мене унікальний досвід Я спостерігаю за
українськими політиками як перекладача
як дипломат як президент колишній двох
телерадіокомпаній як ведучий різних
урочистих заходів і мені завжди було
дуже соромно за Українську політичну
еліту і єдина людина за якою мені жодної
Хвилини не було соромно це п'ятий
президент і я сподіваюся сьомий
президент України і Петро Порошенко
тримаємо тримаємо стрій панове тримаємо
усмішки ширше пам'ятаєте Що Ми веселі
яйця на якесь там Фаберже я
весь час нагадую ким був Зеленський В
2004 році з 2010 році в 2014 році коли
вони були підтанцьовкою цієї банди вони
були справді справжнім антимайданом Вони
їздили підтримуючі Януковича і в
2004-10-му Я вчора якраз згадував під
час ефіру прямого каналу що мені шкода
що свого часу в 2011 році коли я на
власні очі бачив цю обдовбану 95
квартальну банду в готелі
ялта-інтурист коли Я викликав поліції
викликав санітарів так сталося що мій
номер в готелі був в оточений з усіх
боків цілими
[музика]
агентами кримлівськими і вони тоді
настільки нахабно себе поводили що я не
втримався вони о четвертій годині ранку
вони підняли на вуха весь готелі Я
викликав і поліцію викликаю санітарій
для того щоб обдовбаних всіх наркоманів
затримали там Я шкодую що я тоді не за
протоколював свої свідчення Да сьогодні
ця людина опинилася на вершині
політичного олімпунь більше в Україні
сьогодні загрози наші стабільності тому
що він не є абсолютно ніколи не був він
не є самостійним гравцем він був і
лишається маріонеткою
найнебезпечнішого найпіступнішого ворога
сьогодні України
Коломойського проти якого порушені
кримінальні справи п'яти країнах проти
якого працюють сьогодні сотня
кращих фахівців американських Сполучених
Штатах для того щоб вивести його на
чисту воду з того відкрити всі його
оборудки загальна сума цих оборудок які
розслідуються сьогодні в міжнародних
судах в судах спо штатів Британії
470 млрд доларів Уявіть собі яка
сьогодні сума на кону для Коломойського
Тому ми маємо право панове лишатися
осторонь пам'ятаєте цей відомий вислів
бійтеся байдужих саме з їхньою мовчазної
згодою відбувається найбільше злочини на
цій землі тож не лишаємось осторонь
панове тримаємо стрій триваємо усмішки
ширше і тримаємо порох сухим Разом до
перемоги Слава Україні
[оплески]
Слава Україні
Слава нації
Україна
Путін Зеля
дякую
друзі кожного політика творять люди в
кожного відомого політика є свої
прихильники Я чесно кажучи
не можу собі навіть в думках
спроектувати оту картинку коли
Зеленський буде виходити умовно десь на
сцену і перед сценою буде таке волелюдне
віче І власне кожен з людей приїхав по
своїй волі а не якісь скажімо там силою
пригнаний адмінресурс чи проплачена
публіка
кожного політика творять люди і власне
Порошенко то є наше фактично
відображення Кожен з нас хоче вільної і
незалежної України демократичної України
чи не так
і
ми заслуговуємо жити в такій Україні
Ми всі знаємо що
протягом останніх кількох тижнів Петро
Порошенко провів
ряд зустрічей важливих зустрічей
міжнародних у Варшаві у Брюсселі де він
зустрічався з депутатами Європарламенту
де він зустрічався з представниками НАТО
де він говорив з політиками світового
рівня де піднімались питання про захист
України в часі російської агресії власне
в той час коли наш пів шостий відпочивав
в Буковелі коли:30
десь умовно марив мокрими мріями про те
що наш порох буде сидіти
наш порох зустрічався
з людьми свого рівня з великими
політиками і говорив про Україну
домовлявся просив про допомогу і власне
на його заклик як завжди відгукується
друзі зараз попрошу вас звернути увагу
на екран
зараз буде звернення від
5-го президента України і маємо тверду
надію 7 Петра Порошенка
Дорогі українці протягом останніх
кількох тижнів користуючись моїм
закордонним відрядженням Влада
Зеленського докладала всіх зусиль для
того щоб мене залякати вони зфабрикували
абсолютно нікчемно підозру намагалася
провести судове рішення по якому
спробувати
затримати мене для
нібито доставки до суду вони намагалися
заарештувати мої активи причому окреме
виділивши засоби масової інформації які
вже мені не належить Бо саме в цьому є
завдання офісу президента для чого це
робиться перше як я вже сказав залякати
мене і їм це точно не вдасться так само
як ми не боялися Путіна так само як ми
дали йому відсіч ну ж точно не будемо
боятися Зеленського наполегливо радили
мені шептуни і скол Зеленського для того
щоб мені краще не повертатися в Україну
зупинити своє політичне життя і відкрите
зелене світло зеленському грабувати і
нищити Україну
пане Зеленський для вас погана новина 17
січня о 9:10 рейсом з Варшави Я
повертаюся в Україну звичайно не для
того щоб захищатися від вас від того не
варті а для того щоб захищати Україну
захищати Україну від російської агресії
І сьогодні тут в Європі в Брюсселі всі
кажуть що ця загроза для всієї Європи не
лише для України можливо найбільше за
останні 30 років єдине що ви цього не
розумієте захищати від некомпетентної і
не української влади Влади не Роб і
корупціонерів ми будемо перешкоджати
вашим спробам саджати за грати патріотів
волонтерів як ви це
зробили з бойовими генералами які
захищали від Маріуполя до Донецького
аеропорту коли намагаєтеся зробити те що
робить кожний людина яка претендує на те
щоб стати диктатором перетворити
демократію в диктатуру ви хочете
повернути мажоритарну систему Для того
щоб за гречку і через дію купувати
голоси виборців бо це є ваш єдиний шанс
ви хочете ліквідувати виборчу систему з
відкритими списками ви хочете знищити
демократію так само як ви це робили під
час виборів 21-го року ви боїтеся
парламентських виборів і тому ви хочете
їх перенести тому що після
парламентських виборів ви не маєте
шансів виборити президентські і ви
намагаєтесь від досіками про Порошенка
відволікти увагу від ваших прорахунків і
критичної ситуації яку дякуючи вашої
некомпетентності склалася в країні
ви доведете країну до продовольчих
карток ви запровадили регулювання
урядом цін на основні продукти
харчування щоб приводить просто до
зникнення цих продуктів
замість того щоб компенсувати інфляцію
яка виникла вашими зусиллями людям для
того щоб захистити їх від бідності ви це
зробити нездатні були кредити за
останні три тижні
коли Зеленський дуже напружено
відпочивав спочатку Гуті сірмаком потім
в Буковелі з коломойським потім знову в
Буковелі з єрмаком він нібито не помітив
що світ змінився
Росія вдерлася до Казахстану так само як
і колись Радянський Союз вдерся до
Угорщини вдерся до Чехословаччини і це
сприяло перетворенню світу
двополюсний а Радянського Союзу Росії
посилено авторитарну державу яка
насаджує авторитаризм цих країн і
Україна сьогодні має захиститися
захиститися як від військового
вторгнення так як під впливо Росії
Україна зараз потребує рішучих і головне
спільних дій і тому дивує коли з
питаннях України збираються парламенти
всього світу для того щоб спільно
виробити рішення які допоможуть Україні
які допоможуть Європі і світу людина
країна де не збирається парламент
по-українському безпечному питання це є
Верховна Рада України і Отже ми готові
допомагати владі ми готові давати свої
думки свої поради ми готові підставити
плечі якщо треба ми Готові взяти подругу
якщо треба ми готові навіть пересувати
ноги якщо їх ми не йдуть в Європейському
напрямку все це ми готові робити для
того щоби допомогти зеленському бо він є
президентом і в його немічних руках є
булава але як кажуть дубови треба ще й
голови і безумовно що ми як
відповідальна державницька партія будемо
працювати на об'єднання держави
безумовно що ми як державницька партія
будемо підтримувати всі ініціативи які
будуть спрямовані на те щоб посилити
оборонний потенціал нашої держави і
Європейський рух нашої країни як ми це
завжди робили і єдине що я хочу порадити
що коли ми рухаємося в Європу коли ми
прагнемо і говоримо і вимагаємо від тих
країн наших партнерів щоб Україну взяли
в НАТО НАТО беруть демократичні країни а
демократія - це є вільні вибори
зруйнували в 21-му і забираєте руйнувати
в цьому році а демократія це є Свобода
слова бо канали які ви відновлюєте так
звані державнівські які мають займатися
вашою пропагандою нічого спільного з цим
немає так само як і ти намагаєтесь
стиснути на журналістів і тиснути на
незалежні телевізійні канали намагаючись
їх Закрити це знову Перетворення України
в малоросію Януковича демократія це є
захист права позиції демократія це є
верховенство права демократія це є
відсутність вибіркового правосуддя і я
хочу подякувати подякувати за ту
величезну підтримку яку я відчув
протягом останніх 2-3 тижнів
затонет чи найчисельнішу кількість
постів в соціальних мережах СМСок
повідомлень просто слів підтримки і заяв
людей від яких я цього навіть очікував
подякувати простих українців
продякувати священників за молитви і
підтримку подякувати волонтерів
подякувати воїнів які з фронта із пункту
постійної дислокації повідомляють мені
про свою підтримку подякувати
громадських активістів подякувати
політиків причому політиків як
українських так і закордонних Бо питання
України знову якна найкращі часи
об'єднує об'єднує весь світ Всім
об'єднаним світом Ми Точно переможемо бо
з нами правда бо з нами Господь Бог і
слава Україні
давайте
це ще раз повторимо так щоб наш Петро
Олексійович в літаку почув він нашу
відповідь Слава Україні
[оплески]
думаю почув
друзі
завжди завжди в складний час ми з вами
об'єднуємось
об'єднуються
на всі об'єднуються люди на всіх
соціальних рівнях ми всі відчуваємо до
чого куди власне котиться країна точніше
куди котить її Зеленський куди пхає її
Зеленський зі своєю щобою зі своєю
командою і дуже тішить що власне в цей
складний час опозиція об'єднується і так
повинно бути до слова запрошую голову
політичної партії голос Кіру Рудик
Доброго ранку друзі Слава Україні
[оплески]
я Кіра Рудик голова партії голос разом з
європейською солідарністю ми
проукраїнська опозиція в парламенті і
тому я тут
абсолютно очевидно що влада не здатна
виконати жодну свою обіцянку
анатомість вона переслідує про
українську опозицію і тому я тут
Зеленський обіцяв нам що
закінчити війну
закінчити епоху бідності
покінчити з несправедливістю а натомість
він переслідує Петра Олексійовича
Порошенка і це є Єдине чим зараз реально
займається наш президент і тому сьогодні
я тут
президент обіцяв що прийде весна і нам
буде жити набагато краще хто ж знав що
це означає що взимку буде Холодно
холодно тривожно і переслідувати будуть
тих хто здатний врятувати нашу країну і
тому разом з вами я тут
Коли у нас в країні війна і стотисячна
армія ворогів на кордоні про українські
сили об'єднуються тому що є речі
важливіші за політику тому що є речі
важливіші ніж ми це зберегти та
врятувати нашу країну і тому сьогодні я
тут
ви пропонували президенту зеленському
руку допомоги від людей які знають як
воювати з Путіним ми пропонували
президенту зеленському руку допомоги від
людей які були на фронті не перед
телекамерами ми пропонували президенту
зеленському року допомоги від тих людей
які захищали нашу країну до його
президентства І захищатимуть після нього
для того щоб ворог не міг зробити
жодного Кроку вперед
жодного Кроку вперед нашою землею і тому
сьогодні з партією голос Я тут
я тут Тому що для мене країна є набагато
важливішою за політичні амбіції я до
сьогодні за правду за справедливість за
наше з вами майбутнє і за Україну Слава
Україні
дякую вам
і кожен з нас прийшов сюди щоб відстояти
не просто Петра Порошенка а демократію
демократію брати і сестри Кожен з нас
тут є з Україною в серці і Я переконаний
що кожному з нас Україна є найважливішою
правда ж
І зараз я до слова запрошую людину яка
все своє життя живе з цим девізом з цими
словами з Україною в серці Андрій
Парубій
Слава Україні
[оплески]
[музика]
два роки тому
Ми так само в Січневий
день стояли і чекав на томос і тоді я
мав честь разом спецов олексійовичем так
само на літаку привезти український
томос Як черговий етап державотворення у
всі часи наших випробувань ми були разом
плече до плеча і тому будь-яка сила не
могла протистояти Україні сьогодні
Зеленський намагається залякати не
тільки Порошенка він намагається
залякати весь український табір відкриті
кримінальні справи проти багатьох
активістів української громади і
українського табору сьогодні Зеленський
намагається через Порошенка
вискрементувати
майдантувати нашу боротьбу
і це в той час коли на кордоні з
Україною знову збільшується російська
армія коли весь світ говорить про
російську загрозу але Зеленський бачить
загрозу не в Росії Зеленський бачить
загрозу в порошенкаві він його боїться
Він нас боїться він Україну боїться і
тому намагається переслідувати сьогодні
і Порошенка і весь український табір ми
сьогодні демонструємо нашу єдність Ми
сьогодні стверджуємо Зеленський це
тимчасове непорозуміння яке опинилося
сьогодні на посаді президента України Ми
маємо всі
максимально докластись до того що в
цьому швидше Зеленський пішов він
негідний бути Президентом ви негідний
очолювати Україну в період найбільших
випробувань і Я переконаний перемога
Буде за нами як була тоді коли Ми стояли
на Майдані як була тоді коли ми не
хрестили Україну від путінські горки так
І сьогодні разом скажемо як на Майдані
разом сила разом сила разом сила разом
сила разом сила
Україна переможе Слава Україні
Слава нації Україна
до перемоги разом
Дякуємо Пане Андрію Як бачите У нас уже
починаються Маленькі сюрпризи чим ближче
до
прильоту Петра Олексійовича
починається перебої з електроенергією
починається всякі цікаві рухи Але ж ми
готові до всього нас це не лякає
абсолютно
Ми навіть до цього ставимось з іронією
тому що ми на це чекали ну не може бути
так аби ми тут зібралися що була
Зеленського не почала нам пхати палки в
колеса наш Це не лякає правда ж не лякає
Як казав мій покійний дід хрін їм хрін
їм у дупу а нам перемогу друзі зараз Я
запрошую до слова
кіборга
ветерана російсько-української війни
який на
своєму досвіді знає про всю любов братню
братню любов рашки до якої так напевно
прагне наш пів-шостий
депутат політичної депутат Верховної
Ради від політичної партії голос Роман
Костенко
[музика]
смерть ворогам
друзі
Сьогодні ми зібрались тут всі разом в
першу чергу для того щоб показати владі
що ми ніколи не дамо тиснути на опозицію
опозицію яка в свій час з 14-го року
пройшла війну захистила цю країну
відбудувала Підняла її з коліна який
поставила Російська Федерація разом з її
агентами впливу і зараз ті хто прийшли
ми не знаємо де вони були тоді А ні Хоча
знають
і зараз намагаються нам розповісти як
потрібно створювати нову державу я сам
військовий полковник служби безпеки
України і ми ніколи не відступали не
відступали і не давали задню не тоді
коли прийшов ворог до наших кордонів не
тоді коли прийшла влада і почала
переслідувати наших ветеранів волонтерів
Ми пам'ятаємо як ми не відступали коли
переслідували генерала марченка
Антоненка Ми захищали і не дали закрити
справу вагнерів коли Влада хотіла її
просто поховати ми далі захищаємо
розвідників і показуємо всім що ніхто
наше Братство дуже тісне і нікому ми не
дамо кривдити нашу країну зараз тут зі
мною переді мною виступала голова партії
голос Кіра Рудик це жінка яка прийшла в
політику з успішного бізнесу і вона ще
раз показала що жінка може бути успішною
наші українські жінки
вона показує що жінка може бути сильною
Не дивлячись на те що влада тисне на неї
вона створює протидію і говорить слух
про всі провали нашої влади хоча знає як
це може їй загрожувати
і зараз коли в країні енергетична криза
загроза війни епідемія що ми бачимо
Влада замість того щоб боротися з усіма
цими проблемами переслідує позицію Ми
ніколи не дамо цього зробити тому що
Україна не Росія Слава Україні
Україна таки справді не Росія я собі не
можу уявити що в Росії отак шановне
товариство зібралося і висловлювало свою
думку вони там привикли жити як стойлі
вони привикли жити як худоба тому що
інакше То назвати не можна хай мене
пробачать ті адекватні росіяни якщо такі
існують хай мене пробачать але
факт залишається фактом там немає права
на вільні зібрання А ми це право маємо І
ми його будемо відстоювати ми будемо
відстоювати право на демократію дожилися
дожилися зрештою я собі знаєте так думаю
що якби якби ну змоделюємо ситуацію що
мовляв Зеленський хоче стати такі ну
хорошим хорошим президентом що робить
людина яка не має досвіду вона залучає
експертів
не просто скажімо там людей скупленими
дипломами а вона дійсно залучає
експертів Вона залишає людей які мають
досвід реальний досвід
натомість що робить наспівшостий Він
розганяє розганяє фактично всіх людей
які є досвідченими у політиці він на
керівні посади ставить людей абсолютно
без досвіду він ставить таких самих як
він дилетантів які відрізняються одним
чудовим вмінням Вони вміють лизати дупу
а він це любить як виявляється Якби він
залучав до процесу експертів
знавців дійсно знавців міжнародників
моделюючи ситуацію що він хоче стати
дійсно гарним президентом Він можливо
мав би успіх але не судилося я до слова
запрошую Володимира Омеляна політика
експерта дійсно з знавця своєї справи
вам слово Дякую
Слава Україні
я дякую кожному з вас хто прийшов
сьогодні боротися за Україну
так сталося що символом нашої боротьби є
Петро Порошенко і я дуже гордость цього
бо це найкращий президент за останні 10
років він зміг зробити те що не зміг
зробити жоден інший ми мали чудовий в
лапках експеримент Зеленським ми
виправили на власній шкірі Що таке
популізм
коли в державі одна криза змінює іншу це
популізм коли обіцянки розбігаються
справами це популізм і насправді для
себе я ніяк не можу визначити що більше
Зеленський зрадник чи корупціонер
що доби Україна Кожен з нас втрачає
декілька мільярдів гривень через
корупцію ці мільярди не зникають вони
осідають в офшорах Зеленського шефіра
Тимошенко Єрмака Коломойського і інших
зраті Зеленського він це робить свідомо
розповідає Що нам казки що він любить
Україну пам'ятаєте його останні ролик я
дякую кожному з вас так він дякував Бо
насправді він ніколи не міг собі уявити
таке щастя що він за рік стане
мільярдером А за два роки
мультимільєрдером це відбулося тому що
ми мовчали більше мовчати Ми не маємо
права зеллю геть
[оплески]
землю ми маємо досвід наших сусідів коли
Влада була без альтернативною коли
опозиція в тюрмах розстріляна або
знищена в міграції Ми не повинні цього
допустити в Україні можна когось любити
чи не любити може комусь подобатися
гіперлуп чи не подобатися але опозиція
має бути бо якщо не буде критиків влади
ми будемо мати монархію Я не хочу щоб
один Зеленський в Україні змінював
іншого Зеленського бо це дорога в нікуди
ми вільна нація ми сильна нація Ми
повинні дивитися на весь світ
і з прикладом показувати що Україна - це
супер Україна - це круто Україна - це
центр демократії Східної Європи лише так
ми переможемо не закрившись своїх хатах
по своїх домівках а дивлячись на весь
світ і показуючи що українці були і є
успішними в Канаді в Австрії в Польщі
навіть в тій же ж Росії бо ми збудували
Російську імперію якщо хтось забув з
росіян але насправді ми повинні стати
успішними в Україні ми це можемо зробити
і переможемо обов'язково разом Дякую що
прийшли Слава Україні
[оплески]
Як ви знаєте
Зеленський дуже боїться він боїться
всього він боїться масових зібрань він
боїться коли збирається таке шановне
поважне товариство сказати своє слово
і в принципі
це є закономірно він повинен боятися він
повинен боятися тому що він іде не туди
він іде твердим впевненим кроком але
зовсім не туди куди потрібно І власне
президент
свого народу боятися не повинен але лише
за тою умови коли він працює на благо
цього народу коли він працює на благо
України
Коли наш президент пішов Ну я не можу
назвати його шостим для мене він буде
пів-шостим завжди і повсякчас коли він
іде не туди цілком закономірно що він
повинен боятися народу тому що джерелом
влади
є хто народ як народ його виніс так
народ його і знесе єдине що винесли на
п'єдестал його не ми але нам прийдеться
його звідти акуратно зносити
підсаджувати
Бог Добрий і Час покаже що нас чекає в
майбутньому
ще я знаю що Зеленський дуже боїться
жінок
правда ж
і зараз буде мати слово одна з них
екс-депутатка Верховної Ради України
політикиня громадська діячка
журналістка Тетяна Чорновол ваші оплески
я тут абсолютно згодна зеленському
Путіна треба боятися знаєте так
по-старому боятись я не маю на увазі
панічно боятися так щоб готуватись до
того щоб захищати Україну а він боїться
жінок він бореться з жінками і якщо вже
говорити по Петра Олексійовича і нині
переслідування президента 5-го
президента України Я
зауважу таку дуже важливу деталь з
квітня Путін збирає на українському
кордоні війська Він навіть кораблі
перекинув з Каспійського моря в Азовське
чорне він щось готує нічого хорошого Але
чому з квітня підтягує підтягує і наче
чого чекає Я вважаю що він чекає поки
Зеленський тут розправиться з патріотами
Путін боїться українських патріотів саме
тому Зеленський зараз переслідує лідера
партії супротиву не
Ну і солідарності а лідера української
партії супротива тобто цих тих людей і
активістів партійців всіх хто готовий
стати на захист України Якщо Путін буде
наступати і якщо він буде задіяти інші
методи гібридної війни тобто
переслідування Петра Порошенка
Зеленським це ослаблення України на
користь Путіна і на жаль це зараз
відбувається
Зеленський він чи дурень чи реально
працює на Путіна але він ослаблює
Україну Він ослаблює Український фронт
Він ослаблює український супротив
переслідуючи Петра Олексійовича
Порошенка
надзвичайно ослаблює
Зеленський тільки прикидається
Президентом України от саме це слово
прикидається тому що знов-таки якщо ми
говоримо про агресію Росії чому
відбувається переслідування лідера
партії супротива разом тим не заправлені
танки
17% палива було закуплено для потреб
армії в минулому році 17% Путін на
кордоні
а Танки не заправлені пускові
протитанкових стугнень не закуплені
корсарів не закуплені танковий батальйон
для захисту Києва не повернен ми зараз
не захищені від путінського Лукашенка
від путінської Білорусії з цієї сторони
ще раз кажу я була на майданах опозиції
в часи Януковича коли він здавав Україну
знаєте я не погрожувала тоді тим хто
переслідував позицію бо скажу в десятому
році ми були Ну здавалося слабкі але
треба було погрожувати ми знаєте щоб був
Майдан і потім вони всі отримали
А я вже зараз буду погрожувати тому що я
знаю що партія супротиву апріорі
переможе партію капітуляції я буду
погрожувати тому що ми зараз говоримо не
про п'ятого президента України ми зараз
говоримо про переслідування сьомого
президента
хто його переслідує і ще Зеленський
думає що ми будемо збиратися під
лук'янівським СІЗО Ні ми не будемо
збиратися під Луганський сезон ми будемо
збиратися у нього дома Да я йому
погрожуємо ми будемо збиратися у нього
вдома і ще скажу ми партія супротиво нас
вистачить На два фронта і проти Путіна і
проти Зеленського і ми не віддамо цю
країну Ми переможемо бо ми партія
супротиву Путін
за всьому президенту України Петро
Порошенко
Я навіть скажу більше що ми не будемо
збиратися під СІЗО тому що ми цього не
допустимо так
[оплески]
слово має Олександр Турчинов
Вітаю вас патріоти
кому не байдуже майбутнє нашої країни
майбутнє наших дітей Слава Україні
[оплески]
Слава Україні
Влада перелякана
Влада боїться вас
вони планували
щоби ми не могли зустріти літак посадити
його в іншому аеродромі на іншу з льотну
смугу але ми попередили коли ви
будете нам заважати зустрічати Порошенка
Ми будемо зустрічати його на банковій
ваших кабінетах
і зараз літак приземлився до жулян
[оплески]
[музика]
друзі мої брати і сестри
загрожує не тільки Україна
нам загрожує п'ята колона яка сьогодні
при владі нам загрожує Влада не
компетентних корумпованих злочинців і
зрадників це є реальна загроза їхні
компетентність їх корумпованість привела
до страшної економічної кризи через 30
років після Незалежності нам
розповідають про картки на харчі нам
розповідають про те що вони будуть
включати ставково регулювання цін вони
давали країну до галапуючи інфляції коли
так мізерні доходи наших громадян щодня
знецінюються І продовжують грабувати і
грабувати і грабувати продовжують брати
хабарі на своєму великому будівництві
вони не зажруться поки ми їх не зупинимо
друзі мої брати і сестри ми зібрались
тут щоб сказати Ні
поверненню технологія Януковича в нашої
країни якого ми викинули в 14-му році
але зараз знову тотальна корупція зараз
знову повертається авторитаризм зараз
знову відбувається наступна свободу
слова зараз знову вони живуть тільки з
шляхом фальшування виборів і соціальних
досліджень друзі мої вони знову
повернули в країну політичні репресії
замовні справи і неправосудні рішення і
ми говоримо Ні ми не дамо повернути
країну до Савка ми не дамо повернути
країну часи Януковича ми не дамо
зеленському зрадити нашу країну і
віддати її Путіну
з першого дня він почав боротись проти
свого одного конкурента проти лідера
європейської солідарності Петра
Порошенка сотні замовних справ
сотні
слідчих СБУ дбр прокуратури які щодня
фальшували всі брудні замовні справи
вони не змогли навіть вигадати корупцію
що ти Петра Порошенка не змогли вигадати
зловживання службових становищем і тоді
вони пішли на те щоб звинувачувати його
в державній зраді
звинувачувати у державній зраді людину
яка
звільнила з нашої армії дві третини
Донбасу яка повернула Україну до Європи
яка захистила Україну зупинила
економічну кризу і забезпечила сталий
розвиток
зрадники звинувачують державній зраді
друзі вони активізувались знаєте чому
саме напередодні нового року тому що всі
соціологічні служби показали
Порошенка впевнена перемагає Зеленського
в другому Турі
і вони вирішили
кинути його за грати
сподіваючись що ми перерікаємось і
сховаємось ні ні ми прийшли сюди Ми
зараз підемо під Печерський суд ми
підемо на банкову і вся країна підтримує
нас нас підтримують всі патріоти нас
підтримують ті хто готовий захищати як в
14-му році Україну нас підтримує Бог і
це головне вони можуть домовитись з ким
завгодно Але не з ним він з нами тому що
з нами правда тому що з нами Україна
Слава Україні
[оплески]
Олександр Турчинов
потрібен порох в Україні потрібен порох
в Україні потрібен порох
України знаєте я не можу не погодитись з
Олександром валентиновичем про те що Бог
є з нами і він на нашій стороні тому що
з нами є правда А якщо з нами Бог То хто
проти нас
кого ми можемо боятися кого ми повинні
боятися зрештою Не сміє бути в нас
страху тому що з нами є Бог і це головне
14-й рік
загроза повної окупації України ви
пам'ятаєте той час правда
окупація частини Донецької та Луганської
областей окупація Криму
закриття ринку російського ринку для
наших товарів
і Можна би було сказати що ми опинилися
у безвихідному становищі так
Але ж ні приходить Петро Олексійович він
стає президентом з ним приходить команда
і вони разом зі всіма нами Разом з
народом України ми всі разом починаємо
працювати І ми відновили армію так
ми
збудували оту сильну ударну силу яка
спинила Путіна
ви собі тільки подумайте вона спинила
російську навалу наша армія яка колись
була Хай Мене хай мене простять
військові колись вона була ніким але
зараз це одна з кращих армій Європи і
тут не йдеться тільки про
скажімо там про обмундирування про
озброєння Хоча це дуже важливо а тут і
ідеї не наповнення самих бійців
військових
це також є дуже-дуже важливим Друзі за 5
років
президентства Порошенка Ми отримали
безвіз ми зараз у знакому місці Ми зараз
в Жулянах і згадайте коли ми
до отримання безвізу коли ми оформлювали
візи коли Ми стояли в чергах коли ми
терпіли оце приниження А зараз ми просто
беремо закордонний паспорт біометричний
купуємо квиток і летимо туди куди треба
власне з цього аеропорту також Це
дякуючи роботі Порошенка цей аеропорт
також отримав величезний розвиток Ми
отримали томос Ми отримали свою
відновили справедливість церковну Наша
церква повернулася додому друзі я хочу
сказати що зараз ви на екрані можете
бачити кадри з Петром олексійовичем Він
же прилетів до України він приземлився і
ми чекаємо на його з'яву тут А зараз я
прошу також вашої уваги на екрани
ми поки чекаємо Петра Олексійовича
можемо побачити що ж було досягнуто
здобуто за 5 років тому що це були 5
років українських перемог
встановити що Президент України Віктор
Янукович в неконституційний спосіб
самоусунувся від здійснення
конституційних повноважень Та є таким що
не виконує свої обов'язки
советов Федерации федерального собрания
Российской Федерации об использование
вооружённых сил Российской Федерации на
территории Украины
[музика]
відповідно до пункту 7 частини першої
статті 85 Конституції України
призначити
позачергові вибори президента України на
25 травня
2014 року
[музика]
обраним Президентом України є Порошенко
Петро Олексійович
Настав час невідворот позитивних змін
армія та її переозброєння зусиллями
вітчизня
ного від збройні сили Національна
гвардія Державна прикордонна служба
служба безпеки отримали відповідні
накази ми будемо наступати бо вчимося
оборо
няти і тепер ми зможемо випускати такі
ракети які здатні летіти значно далі ніж
зараз І це має стримувати нашого ворога
бо його територія теж стає вразливо
нікому не вдасться здолати Україну ми
готові зі зброєю в руках захищати власну
землю боротися за кожен її клаптик і
Нікому її віддавати не збираємося
Слава
українському народу
в Україні слава
Я використовую весь свій дипломатичний
досвід щоб забезпечити підписання
міжнародного договору який би прийшов би
на
заміну How can you Age and
Fire
write your Roland YouTube
і все полюсі із бо є Бабин
ні з ким не може бути
саме європейське досвід підказує нам що
значну частину повноважень вже зараз
треба делегувати з центру місцевим
органам влади
[музика]
реформа щодо децентралізації
розпочнеться вже цього року змінами до
Конституції
і україна має все необхідне щоб
забезпечити людям європейський добробут
Україна піднялася на чотири сходинки у
рейтингу всесвітнього банку дуем бізнес
з Нового року мінімальна зарплата в
Україні може зрости вдвічі
[музика]
проукраїнських і про європейських сил
нації
спочатку
їм відбирає мову але за останні 5 років
Ми вийшли з преденфактного стану зробили
дуже багато і українською мовою говорить
з нами якісний інформаційний продукт
кіно книга радіо і телебачення розквіт
української мови після століть тотальної
русифікації - це місія яку Нам належить
зверху
завжди було є і буде питанням про
свободу України про нашу свободу і ніякі
наші
[музика]
цих пір не видають паспорт Петро
Порошенко
[оплески]
Чуєте що тебе робить шоу прямо на Ваших
очах друзі
в
[музика]
Дивіться ви бачите всі це шоу цю ганьбу
на прикордонному контролі
адвокат намагається пояснити
що ми йдемо до Печерського суду
а ви хто
проти
не віддають паспорт паспорт не віддають
паспорт
забрали паспорт і не віддають паспорт
заблокований паспорт
громадянина України які не засуджений
народного депутата п'ятого президента
України забрали паспорт не віддають його
тепер влаштовує тут шоу чергове
знімається чергові відосики Зеленського
друзі Подивіться
Чим ви займаєтесь
які вимоги законності ми їдемо в
Печерський суд
ми їдемо в Печерський суд
Що відбувається
[музика]
на території України
дорогі друзі у нас на сьогоднішній день
відбувається зараз
недопуск мене як громадянина України на
територію держави нас на сьогоднішній
день вже більше 10 хвилин
прикордонники не допускають без
пояснення будь-яких причин під приводом
якоїсь перевірки не допускають на
територію України Я думаю що це є
провокація
провокація яка
підбурює до
масових акцій і ми Закликаємо
прикордонників не виконувати злочинних
наказів офісу президента і забезпечити
моє
конституційне право як громадяни
громадянина України доступ на територію
України
в нас на сьогоднішній день є недопуск
мене на території
України випуска
пустіть президента на території України
виконує Злочинний накази
в будь-якому випадку
[музика]
ви можете пояснити дії ваших підлеглих
оце в Зеленій формі
Щодо мого недолеглих оце в Зеленій формі
ви можете пояснити дії ваших підлеглих
Щодо мого недопуску на територію України
адвокати Там ми хочемо пройти що
стається може бути прикордонні купили
вимагає віддати паспорт ДБН
приїхали в Україну паспорт
в руках
бачите пас на думках на кордон паспорт в
руках прикордонника
віддайте будь ласка паспорт мені
ура
Да да да
це розцінювати
що це є порушення закону я Мені просто
дуже шкода прикордонників насправді коли
їх використовують брудних політичних
іграх
проходили
[музика]
1 2
[оплески]
хвилин
і законно
правоохоронці
частина з яких вели переодягнена форму
прикордонників
частина з них була в чорній формі
намагалися не допустити мене на
територію України
вони забрали мій паспорт
вони
пояснювали це що вони мають встановити
мою особу
бо вони мають велику сумніву що я є
Порошенко
вони
більше 15 хвилин перевіряли мій
звичайний
загальнодержавний біометричний паспорт
розробляючи сценарій недопуска мене на
території України так сильно вони нас
чекали
так сильно вони нас бояться так сильно
вони віддають незаконні вказівки
силовікам для того щоб тиснути на
опозицію і
дискредитуючи нашу державу
в умовах
реального зростання
загрози російського вторгнення
і свої зусилля вони спрямували не на
захист держави і не на протидію агресору
А всі свої зусилля вони спрямували
на боротьбу за позицію
виборчим вибіркове правосуддя
руйнації верховенства права
слідкування і тиск
на народних депутатів представників
опозицій Я Хочу наголосити
що ситуацію Нам вдалося вирішити
виключно завдяки тому що в складі
пасажирів рейси яким ми повернулися з
Варшави була величезна кількість
журналістів
я хочу подякувати
самі головним редактору Української
правди
сьогодні Кошкіна
головного берега окремо хоче подякувати
журналістів рейтерс
окремо хочу подякувати журналістів
окремо хочу подякувати журналістів BBC
бо на очах всього світу вони
демонстрували цинічно і
безвідповідальну поведінку так вони
бояться народу Так вони бояться
відповідальності і так сильно Вони
чекали мого повернення що намагалися
перешкодити появі і скажіть мені будь
ласка а вони так хотіли за нами
слідкувати де вони зараз а вони як щури
ховаються від світла тоді коли з'явилася
величезна кількість фотокамер відеокамер
і наших шановних журналістів з вашого
дозволу скільки в мене призначена дата
засідання
[музика]
Я маю зараз підійти до наших пта
хів
виходять колеги
[музика]
[оплески]
которые
[музика]
в нас на 11 годину суд Ми повинні
встигнути
запрошую до слова п'ятого і сьомого
президента України
лінера політичної партії Петра Порошенка
[оплески]
[музика]
скільки нас багато
і нас не подолати дорогі друзі
Дорогі українці
[музика]
я Я дуже скучив за вами
Я дуже хотів щоб ми як раніше зустрілися
вітаю вас
Мені приємно що тут сьогодні абсолютно
більшість знайомих обличчя
це разом з вами ми
робили Революції гідності
це разом з вами дорогі волонтери і
добровольці
ували армію
роках
[музика]
забезпечити Андрію
Слава Україні
разом з громадськими активістами
ми виборювали
представниками малого та середнього
бізнесу
ми забезпечили
48-місячних
[музика]
Тіра голос ми з вами дякую
це разом з вами
шановні дипломати де вони ричали я бачу
Де Кості лісів
це разом з вами ми
забезпечували підписання імплементації
про асоціацію
підписання
угоди про всеохоплюючи зону вільної
торгівлі з Європейським Союзом
з вами шановні дипломати ми
забезпечили ми звільненням
Ще раз вам з вами
ми забезпечили протистояння
і інформаційні
[музика]
і агресії
військові
і треба зараз з вами
для того щоб ніхто
не
вирішувати
свій рух в Європу
ми з вами Зробили щоб Україна ніколи не
повернулася і не перетворилася в
новоросію
де таких як
Таких как Юрій Луценко Юра
Юра
будуть кидати за грати
але не допустимо
кіно
сьогодні
вони перетворюють
самі перетворюються в Януковича
а відкидають нас назад на 10 років
і ми тут для того щоб
не для того щоб захистити Порошенка ми
тут для того щоб об'єднатися і захистити
Україну
бо
Я дуже шаную люблю
мою улюблену європейську Солідарність
Я дуже люблю справу громади
братів по зброї
але дуже важливо що сьогодні разом з
нами
представники інших політичних
демократичних сил які зараз є символом
нашого об'єднання Зараз ми разом маємо
об'єднатися і показати що об'єднана
Україна сильна а сильно вона здатна дати
відповідь Путіну
я не відкрию вам таємницю коли скажу що
вони нас бояться
20 хвилин
вони мене п'ятого президента лідера
опозиції
намагалися не допустити в Україну
вони стягну
вони стягнули переодягнутих
прикордонників і на очах
журналістів всього світу
треба було підтвердження що я є
Порошенко
вони прямовали підтвердження
що паспорт Порошенка - Це мій справжній
вони інопланетяни бо вони не пізнали
мене
і так вони хотіли зі мною зустрітися що
лякалися і тікали від камери як чорт від
ладан
бо вони бояться вас
чому
вони намагалися
заявити про те що ми скоїли злочин для
мене це не новина за три роки ці
негідники порушили більше 120
кримінальних справ проти мене і проти
вас
[музика]
справи порушення за наказ про
Контрнаступ справи порушені за
створення нормандського формату справи
порушені за здійснення і укріплення
обороноздатності
але коли вони порушили справу про
державну зраду це є перетин червоних
ліній
це виклик не тільки мені це виклик всі
нам і всім п’яти рокам з 14 по 19-й коли
ми з вами будували державу створили
[музика]
національну ідентифікацію прийняли закон
про мову зробили декомунізацію
і багато-багато іншого включно з армією
мовою
і Вірою
для них це державна зрада
спасибі
[оплески]
Спасибі дорогі друзі
І сьогодні тут нас
тисячі
15 тисяч людей тільки
зібралися в аеропорту Жуляни для того
щоб не дати їм чинити провокації
А хто же
звинувачує нас зраді
А ті хто коли захоплювали Зелений
чоловічок і Крим і дуже добре про це
може розповісти ахтем чийкозе мустафара
вони
знімали фільми в Москві знімаючи
відосики на Красній площі
тоді
коли катували рибака в Горлівці
вони
членам грали на роялі вважаючи що Це є
символ культури моєї України
вони
[оплески]
зрадники українських військових які
кидали за грати
українських кіборгів офіцерів генералів
спецназьорів рік Мастера для того щоб
отримати
політичні дивіденди
значна частина сидить в'язницях і далі І
зараз вони це ті хто злили ізрадили
українських розвідників
передавши Путіну і Лукашенко дані по
операції Вагнера вони це ті хто руйнують
міжнародну коаліцію на підтримку України
займаючись крадіжкою людей в країнах
наших союзників
вони
це ті хто Зеленський разом з
коломойським як свідчить Пандора пейперс
десятки мільярдів мільйонів доларів
витягаючи з кишень платників податків
крали
і клали собі в кишеню і тоді поки ми з
вами будували фундамент нашої
державності
вони таємно Зеленський з коломойським
витягали з цього фундаменту кирпичики
і будували свої квартири в Лондоні і
Віллі в Італії
руйнуючи Україну
і вони набралися наглості збожеволіли
нас всіх звинуватити в державній зраді
вони будуть нести за це відповідальність
Але зараз я вас хочу привітати з першою
маленькою перемогою генерал Павловський
давайте продуємо правоми генералу який
звільняв Маріуполь
[оплески]
але
сьогодні в нас вже є перша перемога
маленька але важливо вони збиралися
затримати нас в аеропорту
і злякалися вас
бо ви сильні Ви молодці Ви знаєте і
вмієте як перемагати Це перша але дуже
важлива перемога Я вітаю вас з нею
і Хочу наголосити У нас попереду ще
багато перемог
я
Вітаю ваше лозунги Я не є їх автором але
це дуже круто а й lb-бек
Боже мій правий
ви казали
що країні потрібен порох
[оплески]
все у вас порох є
і разом Разом до перемоги
Зараз
я рухаюсь на суд де ми дамо їм бій і
покажемо їх брехливу
антидержавну сутність ми покажемо як
вони зраджують державу ми покажемо що в
умовах коли країна потребує єдності
об'єднання для того щоби сильною
виступити на протидію Путіна та відсіч
Путіна як ми це зробили в 14-му 15-му
роках
Я вас всіх чекаю біля суду я дякую що ви
не залишились байдужими і з усієї
України приїхали сюди Ви
продемонстрували що ні Мороз ні
спецпризначенці і поліція не
переодягнені які не пізнають Порошенка
вони нічого не вийде бо правда правда з
нами
Бог Господь Бог він з нами і перемога
наша спільна перемога попереду
Слава Україні
[оплески]
Дякую що ви не залишились байдужими і з
усієї України приїхали сюди Ви
продемонстрували що ні Мороз ні
спецпризначенці і поліція не
переодягнені які не пізнають Порошенка
вони нічого не вийде бо правда правда з
нами
бо Господь Бог він з нами
і перемога наче спільна перемога
попереду
Слава Україні
[оплески]
[музика]
О Боже
Ми йдемо
в бідним ходом твердіним світ
незламнімо українець по
[оплески]
плачений кому ще з
[музика]
[оплески]
собою велику суть для усіх єдину на
[музика]
впевнена да Перемоги
Слава Україні
товариство повторюю ще раз Олександр
Валентинович сказав дуже чітку необхідну
для всіх інформацію повторюю ще раз
зараз Петро Олексійович супроводі
автоколони з визначених автомобілів
рухається до Печерського суду нам
критично важливо встигнути до 11-ї
години до початку судового засідання це
раз решта товариства яке приїхали сюди
організовано автобусами будь ласка
Сідаємо до автобусів Сідаємо до автівок
і організовано пересуваємось
перемішуємось до Печерського районного
суду
без без штовханини організовано і
спокійно брати і сестри ми всіх вас
чекаємо біля Печерського районного суду
тому що там зараз буде відбуватись
судилище і ми повинні захистити наше
право на чесний і справедливий суд на
демократію разом сила
[музика]
шановні друзі
шановні друзі величезна подяка всім хто
прийшов і в мене прохання я вів стрім
самої Варшави зі свого телефонах Може
хтось і дивився в тому числі в літаку
але коли ми тут виходили хтось вибив
телефон і він впав та у друзі Хто знайде
телефон в Чорному чохлі будь ласка
Олексій Гончаренко підходьте це
історичний телефон який пройшов з нами
весь цей шлях дуже буде шкода його
загубити Але хай це буде найбільше
звичайно наша сьогодні горе і друзі всі
до Печерського суду